anna loos ist lebens- und
berufsberaterin durch ihren job ist sie
viel in sozialen netzwerken aktiv auf
facebook hat sie mehr als 1000 freunde
einige davon bekamen dort plötzlich
merkwürdige nachrichten geschickt
scheinbar von erna hüls selbst auf
einmal kriegt ich eine sms nach der
anderen und anrufe auf meinem handy aus
war bestimmt zehn sms und dann gebe
nicht rangegangen und eine freundin
sagte erna ich habe mit ganz komische
nachricht gekriegt über facebook mal
nach da stimmt was nicht das bist du
doch nicht
sie schaltet sofort ihren computer an
und merkt dass unbekannte ihr komplettes
facebook-profil kopiert haben
die täter haben freunden vom falschen
profil aus nach einer
freundschaftsanfragen geschickt sogar
mit persönlicher nachricht die freunde
die darauf reagierten bekamen später
noch eine nachricht
darin bat die vermeintliche erna hüls um
500 euro
leihweise sie würde am nächsten tag
sogar eine höhere summe zurückzahlen
wer mich kennt weiß dass ich so was
nicht tun würde
aber da ich mehr als 1000 freunde haben
da bin ich wirklich hab ich wirklich
richtig panik gekriegt computerexperte
jörg schieb erklärt die betrügerische
masche die täter bauen bestehende
facebook-profile nach samt profilfoto
und usernamen dann bitten sie die
freunde des opfers um geld da ist
natürlich eine hilfsbereitschaft das
wird eine soziale ader quasi
angesprochen und da fällt nahezu jeder
drauf rein war keiner kommt auf die idee
regelmäßig zu kontrollieren ist diese
facebook-seite jetzt wirklich echt oder
bin ich da eine falle getappt
erna hüls nutzt ihren facebook-account
vor allem beruflich deswegen sind die
meisten inhalte öffentlich einsehbar für
kriminelle sind solche accounts
besonders interessant je mehr
öffentliche daten desto leichter der
betrug facebook gründer mark zuckerberg
hat angekündigt den kampf gegen
gefälschte profile zu verstärken dass
die user können solchen betrug auch
vorbeugend durch strenge privatsphäre
einstellungen
deswegen sollte ich hingehen und diese
freundesliste verstecken ich kann das
machen nämlich auf die freundesliste
gehe und dann die privatsphäre
einstellungen auswählen und dann kann
nicht festlegen kann jeder sehen mit dem
ich befreundet bin oder eben nur meine
freunde und diese einstellung sollte man
vornehmen auf der sicheren seite zu sein
erna hüls hat ihre freundesliste
inzwischen versteckt so sorglos wie vor
dem zwischenfall geht sie mit facebook
nicht mehr um
zum glück hat keiner ihrer kontakte geld
an die betrüger überwiesen